so we stopped here with this say
adaptive procedure and we'll just to
mention the surprising result by
Blanchard and recurrent very recently
that if one instead restricts the story
estimator to very small ones that is we
measure how many big ones we have but
not over the upper half but going all
the way to say to point 05 to the same
level as you then this thing dreams that
the variance brings back and then we are
doing but better and almost controlling
and instead these two have some very
nice additional results about that okay
the third one is I would like to explain
the third and it's especially because I
want to use it later on but it's also
one of the things that are that we have
a proof about and it just i would like
to mention so it's the third adaptive
method and it's in a sense a combination
of home and the bh in what sense if you
remember what I showed with the home you
start with p 1 and at each step you
compare p I with alpha over n plus 1
minus I I mean this is the the size of
the family that you have at stage I at
stage one you have em at stage two you
have a minus 1 and so on and so forth
and you stop whenever with the first non
rejection now the multistage if they are
controlling procedure you also start
with P one with the smallest p value and
work your way up at each time you
compare pi/2 few over I now remember we
in the adaptive case you want you to
have am NOT we put it n plus 1 minus I
times 1 minus Q so not minus I because
among they are you might have Q which
are false discoveries so you're not sure
your show only about 1 minus Q and you
work your way up to higher p value
reduces the size of the family each time
you go up by one minus Q and you stop
with the first non rejection and what
you have really is forget the phone line
what you get
really is that you have both FDR
controlling properties of this procedure
and asymptotic optimality asymptotic
optimality in the size of the problem
under independence is the size of the
problem increases what you get is this
kind of procedure this are these the way
the constant look so see it's over here
it's linear with the same slope as the
linear step up the bh procedure and then
you allow yourself more and more as you
go up until at the end you compare with
I over and plus Q I mean you really is
sorry you compare at em over n plus Q
very close to one if you plug in here M
you will get here and here you'll get em
over n plus Q so at the end if you got
there everything is fine you can allow
yourself a lot of leeway ok i will use
this in the continuation of desert talk
now i want to just briefly present two
areas which i will not talk about one is
the base in empirical bayes approaches
it started with two sure f weren't shown
it all in the context of gene expression
analysis if you threshold significance
and there at that time it was four
thousand genes if you threshold the
significance in some alpha some a then
you can define the positive FDR which is
the expected value of V of egg / our
face so this is the the proportion given
that your projected something so this is
the condition of the positive part that
appears and so it is almost there it's
FDR if you threshold at a divided by the
probability that you will reject
something and in large problem this is
approximately the same as FDR but this
can this can reach this cannot be always
control f1 continued with this line of
work and with paper starting from the
point of one paper with a few more and
then his recent large-scale inference
book very nice very very illustrative
and people
10 and he talks about this approach at
length he defines FDR ok you see the
capital in the f he apologized and said
it's such a good name that he can't
avoid it so his 6fd RNA and this is the
expected value divided by the expected
value ok instead of the expected value
of the proportion expected value divided
by theta and this is in large problems
it's the same as if they are on the same
as the positive FDR but then you can
take its derivative and you get the
local FDR which is essentially getting
close to the base factor and so on this
is peanut which is the proportion null
hypothesis times the density under the
null divided by the density of the
distribution that you have it's peanut f
naught X plus e1 f1 of X oh you have
really did they base a factor and the
empirical bayes in it is estimating
peanut that is the adaptive methods we
use these are the empirical part here
and in later work also even estimated f
not to make it empirical and so this is
despite selfie the whole talk that like
I cannot get into it and worth listening
from f1 himself the other i think i will
not get into is weighted FDR so far we
have looked at all hypotheses equally
everything was on equal footing in a way
weighted procedure make distinction each
I potus's H I receives a weight WI and
now we can do two things I mean it with
the son of the way it's being equal to
the sum of the hypothesis we can try to
capture by the way it's the importance
of each hypothesis separately by
defining a weighted FDR some of Wiri
that is if I reject who are the wave on
it's probably some of WI VI divided by
the sum of wi li and so it really allows
us to to give monetary value to each
rejection and and and this will be the
wasted costs
in our discoveries all the other one is
by Genovese and wasserman the advantage
you give advantage to the church
policies by taking these people you and
divided it so it this one can be bigger
than one so you just lower the pier
annual I mean you clearly give it
advantage of course it gets to come on
the expense of other ones that will have
less than one weight and so they will
get disadvantage in being discovered for
all for both of them and actually even
you can use this one you and FDR is
defined just as before and both are in
my opinion underutilized in practice and
they are important but I will not get to
them maybe that's the reason they're
good luck ok so that was the plan to end
of the first part and let's go to the
second part
by the way our FDR wasn't easy to be
accepted in the nineteen ninety at eight
one of the currently workers in the
field helmet filler started the stock by
showing the tone stone and saying here
lies the FDR we found some terrible
fault in it it doesn't control the
family why 08 I mean we give up
something in order to gain this okay so
what I'm what I want to talk now about
the false coverage rate and you will see
that now some of some of the ideas just
appear again some are new what appears
again is the fact that the marginal
standard ninety-five percent confidence
intervals they offer the probability
that the marginal interval covers its
parameter is probability 95 or
equivalently the probability that it
fails to cover its parameter is point oh
five pieces for a single confidence in
the world made on a single parameter now
with many such intervals the probability
that some intervals will fail to cover
increase to above point 05 and using
simultaneous confidence interval simply
issues that for all of them together
there will be less than point 05 so so
far there is nothing nothing you but the
fact is that people treat the problem of
multiplicity as less severe with
confidence interval okay you can find
many many reasons for that in
epidemiology that says I potus's testing
is simply no good you should do
confidence interval now confidence
interval you shouldn't adjust for
multiplicities on the post-hoc analysis
took post-hoc analysis that you have to
adjust for instantly so you're doing
better science you shouldn't be punished
for doing better science by confidence
interval but an in confidence interval
more than that why do we bother about
multiplicity what is the property of a
confidence interval
the confidence is that on the on the
average it will fail in less than point
05 but the expected proportion of
intervals that failing to cover is also
less or equal to point 05 if you are
doing 100 confidence interval on the
average it will also be less than point
05 so my father at all okay so let me
explain you what bothers me at least
that and why I care about it okay so we
have 20 parameters and I want to
estimate them with ninety percent
confidence interval and these are the
true values of the parameter and you see
the one actually well you may argue this
one but nothing is zero so the null
hypothesis is never too fine they are
not true now I have estimators for each
one of these parameter I have an
estimator of course they're very widely
but that's fine the confidence interval
I put one confidence interval ninety
percent confidence interval about them
and we see that some intervals cover
their parameters and son do not cover
the perimeter this one fails to cover
its parameter but if I'm looking on the
average only three out of the 20 do not
cover their parameter I made it ninety
percent confidence interval so this
should come as no surprise there are
having one coverage but let's look now
at all those intervals that do not cover
0 okay now this one doesn't cover this
one cover this one and this one now I
have for that don't kavitha and let me
select those that do not cover 0 okay
now once I select this three out of the
four do not cover one selected okay
while there is no potus's testing the
null hypothesis is never to just a
matter of coverage when i select
coverage deteriorates may deteriorate
and the more extensive the selection the
more likely it is to not being able to
cover even on the average their
properties of debt now this is partly
the reason why in
many studies when you look at the bigger
ones then in later studies they shrink
back I mean in later studies the same
phenomena doesn't appear as surprising
as it was before it was selected in the
beginning now it's interesting that are
batting is safe from this the effect of
selection even bayesian intervals they
seem not to be late that may have the
same phenomenon and there's a paper by
wang and like a curse and more recently
by equity le explaining this point and
making the distinction well it doesn't
when it does not so let us define a full
coverage statement rate which means that
if i have data t and i'm going to select
some and i'm going to select based on
the data a set of parameters and to stay
confident suitable only for the selected
set that we define the full coverage
statement rate fcr of a selective
confidence interval procedure as the
expected number of the number of
intervals that i'm making that failed to
cover their respective perimeter the
perimeter is not in the confidence in
the one divided by the number selected
from looking at the proportion of
intervals that i make that fails to a
very natural or think again our s may be
0 may select nothing in which case the
ratio is 0 and fcr is the expected
portion of coverage statement made the
trail to cover their respective
parameters and similarly i have an FC
our adjusted selective confidence
interval procedure which surprisingly
takes into consideration only the
numbers selected so the FDR selected
confidence interval senior is applied a
selection criteria and for each I in the
selected construct a marginal confidence
interval but at a more conservative
level what is the conservative level the
numbers selected divided by the number
from which I selected the potential
number that could
selected so i inflate the confidence
interval in this direction and at their
own states are that for any simple
selection procedure s if each marginal
confidence interval is monotone in alpha
that is if I take in point 05 a 95 level
mountain confident it will be shorter
than 99 will be sure the number natural
condition and if the component of the
teal detect estimators are independent
of positive regression dependent then
the above FC are just at sea I enjoy
that fcr is less or equal to Q and I
believe that many oh look at that can
see the connection between fdfd are and
the fcr because essentially what you
have is that if you test what mu i equal
to zero and you select the controlling
the FDR with bh then exactly what you
have is that you select I if and only if
the fcr just that confident suitable
doesn't cover you because here you have
r over m the number that rejected over m
okay ss4 the original bh if the
selection is I that is if you select s
is small and wider intervals are needed
if s is one these are the bonferroni
confidence interval because they are at
level 1 over m and if all I've selected
nothing is needed because the number
selected over m is one and if there is
no selection on the average it's fine I
mean whatever you do with each single
one so the fzr adjustment is adaptive
simple that he stated up in the theorem
need not be that simple it is a
bonferroni testing unadjusted testing
using BH using the largest k and so on
and so forth they're all simple in this
respect adaptive FDR testing is not
simple but the only difference between
simple and not so simple is the
definition of number you count in a more
complex way which I will not go into it
you count how many effective number that
you have and this effective number might
be different and then you plug the
effective number there instead of this
actually the number but in many
situations is now let me emphasize again
if you select not based on the data that
you're watching you don't have to worry
if you pre defined what you would create
confidence interval there's no problem
this is the problem here is again that
you do the analysis and then select what
is interesting and what is not and so
this is the important point let me give
you an example of a massive selection
and this time is done not by the
abstract but by the table this is a very
important study replication of
genome-wide Association signals in UK
samples that do analysis for type 2
diabetics the connection between type 2
diabetes and the scan of the genome this
is the table in the paper
you can't read it of course I don't
expect it to read it but what you have
here is a list of 10 slips just and
snips and you have here different
studies in which it was tested and so on
then looking at all combined fourteen
thousand cases 7,000 concall and what
you have you is the odds ratio I mean
for those who are not familiar it's the
increase in risk approximately the
increase in risk you if you have this
this slip into one form or another and
so it's 117 112 and so on this is the
estimator combined studies and this is
the confidence interval and since you
can see here it is again so you have the
list of clips you have the odds ratio
and then you have the regular
ninety-five percent confidence interval
now this is typical in the sense that
this was this word tested and adjusted
in fact they were adjusted using
something some version up on ferroni and
so only ten were selected out of about
400,000 and so the p-value that exists
there are extremely high but when it
comes to the confidence interval this is
the regular marginal confidence interval
so you see here that say you have here
from seven percent to seventeen percent
for 14 to 25 8 220 m it is not a very
strong strong results relative in this
kind of studies okay now if you do look
at it with FC are adjusted see eyes and
the factor there instead of paying a
point 05 it's point oh five times ten
over 400,000 then this are the fcr
justed confidence interval and you see
that it goes from 1 to 1 30 there's from
1.1 so maybe there is an addition only
one percent here that's also reasonable
and from 32 36 and suddenly the
uncertainty that is merely due to the
selection is much larger you will not be
surprised to find only one percent
increase in your next study again this
unfortunate but this is this is the way
it is
it is done how well do we do with this
kind of procedure that I showed you is
it does it have any sense of optimality
or something like that well sometimes it
is the best that there can be done under
some additional condition if for all I
you have some UI and do I either is very
biggle or is it 0 then what you have for
the fcr is that it goes from 0 point 0 5
all the way to point 05 and no more than
point 0 to 5 so this is at most what you
can gain in some situation okay but the
story is more complicated than that and
for that I have to do a simulation and
show you the result so here there are
10,000 estimators of 10,000 estimators
and here you have the observed y and
this is the effect size and what you
have is a threshold it was done using a
threshold of the bh so only these were
selected and the selection was at 3.11
so these are the values that were
selected they are brought in this form
so that this is the unadjusted
confidence interval and this is the fcr
adjusted confidence interval this will
be in one place and observation move
around so the confidence interval will
cover if the point falls inside it will
not cover if it falls outside okay and
what we see clearly is that the
unadjusted are really bad is it the red
ones or the unadjusted and many
observation fall outside of it and in
fact if we look at the green one which
is the fcr adjusted when we are doing
quite well here I mean there's nothing
there a few here that come out of here
so on the average over the selected we
are doing very nice right in this in
this situation however if you look here
they're much too white I'm end up we are
not even even the regular would have
been done well indeed in this direction
now why is that that's because we have
chosen the biggest
by choosing the biggest we have created
bias in the direction in this direction
so we have to we have to increase in
this way but it seems that if you choose
this method you don't need to go that
far in the other direction that is the
method of selection can be utilized in
order to maybe get a better selective
influence confidence interval and
possibly also tests so that the next our
next couple of minutes what I want the
to show is exactly what happens on on
this on this kind of think until and
then the lesson I'm trying to drive in
is that we can do we can do better than
merely protect against any selection
which is worth the FDR does and birthday
and what is or the bh procedure does and
this kind of so the point is there is
the following in particular let me take
the selection of a parameter if it's
estimator is big enough so i'm going to
i have wise but i'm going to use why
only if it is bigger enough so this is C
can be the significance level can be as
before and so she can be either fixed or
simple data dependent I have this one
and this will be my criteria and so if i
look at the conditional distribution
they are very different from the
original distribution this is the
original gaussian distribution with new
here if i take the conditional one out
here then it goes up here and here
course it is 0 if mu is shifted and now
mu is here then now I have this density
here with this density here and so on
and so forth if I further move then it
will be something like that if I move
far enough it will then resemble the
regular Gaussian I would be very far
away from be very far away from from the
threshold and I will
suffer okay so that's it now this
complicates life a lot because not only
tetas now doesn't merely isn't really a
shift of the distribution it now changes
completely in shape but still we can
create the chest for each one of these
tests whether we're the theta equals one
whether it work equals one point one we
can do it by looking at them maximum
likelihood test that is we will cut at
some point here and we'll take if the if
the probability here is point 95 this
will be the acceptance region I'll
reject ones fall outside I will take
here this is the idea of the maximum
likelihood that they I have to take the
line like that okay now so we're going
to have a test like that but I would
like to add something something else to
death notice that if we are out here and
I'm cutting here again very little from
this extra one well this acceptance
region has a different sign than the
original one maybe I can take this just
a little bit here and then I'll avoid
crossing with my test in the other
direction I can gain sign determination
and in fact this is the idea behind the
quasi conventional confidence interval
we design an acceptance region for
testing tetas equal theta naught which
have the correct level under the
conditional distribution when theta is
the 21 but the condition is plus or
minus C the condition doesn't move it
stated it moves there are as short as
possible but they also include avoiding
observation of the opposite sine 2 theta
naught and this is the idea that we've
been exploring with my work with
Philippa for quite a while and then we
invert this to get the conditional
confidence interval and the point is
that since we designed them
conditionally they control the false
coverage rate because there are each one
separately and when they average each
one of them have the right coverage when
I average them they're fine so we
our overcame the problem of selection by
defining for the selected when based on
the property that they were selected let
me show you how they work okay so this
is example from an online study with
Tull my handler psychiatrist at the tel
aviv university there were 16 subjects
and they viewed to movie segments of
different stress levels and then using
fMRI technology my technology activity
voxels in the brain was registered and
at the same time the level of cortisol
in their blood was measured our cortisol
signalling also stress in in terms of
hormone level and the goal was to
estimate the correlation between these
differences and inactivity and the
difference in cortisol levels across
subjects and to do that in promising
voxels in order to identify on the map
where are these promising voxels okay so
there were fourteen thousand such
correlations one for each voxel and
interest lies only in boxers from which
the correlation is high our is bigger
than point 63 determined and there were
15 voxels with our bigger than point six
and twenty-one voxels with our less than
point six and it is the picture that
they have this is our bigger than point
six look at the positive ones and what I
have here is the estimated correlation
so this will be linear it is this is
point six and so on up to 0 point is 69
and these are the regular confidence
interval the marginal confidence
interval on the correlation now they are
not symmetric because we use the Fisher
transformation and go back on it this is
a statistical
I guess statistical magic but the point
is that they are correct confidence
interval for the correlation coefficient
and they go from from here to here and
so these are the marginal confidence
interval and these are the conditional
once they go from here to here you see
that they extend down much more than the
marginal one extend down exactly doing
the work they were supposed to do in
this direction going up the extent when
the correlation is high as much as the
regular one notice the killed or even
lower than the regular one you don't
even have to go up to the regular one
and they're still offer the right
coverage on the average in fact some of
them go below the zero I mean the
selection was at point six some of them
something less than zero is also
reasonable it's very interesting but in
a recent study that were making we find
out that it is better than splitting and
learning splitting the data to learning
and testing okay in the sense that if
you because we use we used to look for
this 16 okay for this is bigger than
point six and then that we can do it by
splitting the data and use half of the
data to find the voxels and then half of
the data to estimate confidence interval
then we can put regular confidence
interval it's fine because it's used you
didn't use the same data in order to put
the confidence interval and that's what
happens is that when you use half of the
data both your you discover much less
because you don't use all of the data so
you discover less voxels in the brain
and the second thing is that if you use
the other half the confidence intervals
are much wider because you have less
data for each point and so it turned out
that this is much more sensitive
surprisingly maybe but it's more
sensitive than splitting the data and do
training and learning go estimation and
validation or whatever you call it and
we have a software for that in the
upcoming Joseph paper okay so estimation
and model selection is the last thing
that I want to I guess this lasting
almost lastly the tie will discuss in
detail and the motivation is wavelet
analysis where you have a function with
L equally spaced you estimate the
wavelet coefficients on of your
estimated normally distributed random
them around with the true value of the
coefficient with signal square which can
be known and they are independent so the
theory is finite that's why we started
with that and it is known that you can
threshold small coefficient and rec
instructor the noise single from debt
and so the idea is you transfer me to
the wavelets you look at the
co-efficient the estimated small once
you set to zero you keep the big ones
and then you transform it back to the
original one and you get a denoise
function it's done with it can be done
with other bases not necessarily with
the wavelets and so on and so forth what
is the statistical idea behind it the
idea is that if the size of the
coefficient is smaller than the variance
of its estimator just forget it zero it
out because if you try to estimate it
you want to this ignores so the only
thing is that we don't know who is small
and who is big if an Oracle gives us we
small with big then we're a better
situation will compare what we do
otherwise to that situation but the
point is that we can test for them you I
is 0 or not and this is actually the
heart fresh holding and the bonferroni
method is equivalent to the universal
threshold of Don Juan Johnson which is
sigma x to load the square root of two
log em with em
the number of observation of the number
of coefficient our people aware of this
hot was holding and so on or is it
something I see quite a few nodding so
that's fine oh okay from our point of
view what we what I'm looking at is the
fact that i have many parameters mu I
turned I have estimated which are no
distributed about them and I'm looking
at some function of them oh and the
question is if testing is good and what
finally works well what would FDR do on
that instead of bonferroni used FDR so
this really introduces us to test
amasian at estimator at estimator is
something that you first test and then
estimate so the idea is you you
calculate PK I know you're not
interested in in hypothesis testing in
all you're still interested in
estimation but you first test to see if
it is big or not you look at all of them
and you find the FDR threshold the K
that you find out so that means that you
compare this one in here that means that
you threshold when your estimator is
bigger than Sigma times the normal a
quantile with exactly this point ok and
then you estimate by changing your
estimator 20 if you're below this
threshold and you keep it the same if
you're above the threshold then you
report it so if this is this testing is
exactly how threshold ago now then use
this why FDR instead of y and this is
widely used when you screen hundreds of
tons in tow of jeans for example and you
start to you want to model them and your
ability to model is working with
thousands of variables and not with
hundreds of thousands of variable so
this service the initial screen and then
you continue to work with what remains
there that's exactly the leg point now
the interesting interestingly there is
are some theory for this situation and
quite the strong result that being
derived if we measure the performance of
the estimating vector by the expected lr
loss any are between 0 and 2 that is we
both measure it in terms of the sum of
square or the sum of the absolute
deviation or something getting closer
and closer simply to counting the number
of errors that we make when our gets
close to zero okay no matter what are
what we have and we do it relative to
the best Oracle performance the best
Oracle performance meaning the one who
tells us who is beacon who is more and
we let the number of parameters go to
infinity and we deal with bodies of
sparse signals where I will not go into
the mathematical part of it but the
interesting part is you look at the
proportion of nonzero coefficient and
you let them go to zero that is the
feedlot M goes to one I mean you're
torching the situation where most of it
is our zeroes null and very fewer than
on the other extreme none of them is
zero but just the size of the sorted
coefficient the case first so really
fast decay under this condition you have
the top recording by FDR testing of the
coefficient which q less than a half is
adaptively minimax simultaneously over
bodies of spa signals and over all those
loss function meaning that counting
errors interesting just FDR is counting
the number of hours counting the errors
relative to the things that you keep
allows you to get all of of this result
the water whatever we learned from this
theory first of all the importance of Q
less than half because if Q is bigger
than a half it explodes I mean there's
no mean you have to keep their if they
are at levels less than our doesn't
matter that much but don't get close to
half and we see it in in practice that
this is the case second thing is that
FDR testing is relevant and is works
well even when no I potus's is true i
mean we started with the mechanism for
our potus's testing we're using it
verb it doesn't have to be not all of
them too why does it work this way
somehow if you have small new eyes the
worst situation is when the small new
eyes are zero so testing protects you
gets it to zero not because 0 is the
real thing but because 0 is the one you
protect against when the blue eyes are
small the third thing that we learned is
that actually the proof are a partial
proof take some 60 pages in the annals
of statistics mostly the work of
Johnston and then Donna han najin
telling in best piece of work but the
way the proof is done is by looking at
the penalized min sum of square ok where
the penalty is of this form what is this
form I'm taking z 1 over m times 2 so
this is the quantile of 1 over m times Q
then the quantile of two of our
interview so those are the constants
from the FDR from the bh testing and
they r squared and they are sound and
this is the this is the sum of squared
error and the Furies done for that and
if you will see what does it mean well
if I estimate something if I have
something estimate something they expect
they the prediction is it itself so i
have y i minus y0 so everything that i
estimate this part is 0 what I have here
is all the small ones their remaining
ones and for each one that appears here
I carry its relative zi square over here
now when do I choose to to estimate
another one if what I gained from this
element here is bigger than the last
element there then I might as well bring
it this one here and that point they're
so essentially it is like it is very
close to FDR testing if you look for the
global minimum of that and in fact what
the prof goes is that the mint the
overall minimize
is very close to the for the first
minimizer and the last minimizer which
is using this constant in a backward or
in a forward situation or step up or
step down so both control the FDR now
under this setting what maybe we can
step out of the auto gun ality that
exists in the wavelet analysis and
before and moving the speculative land
of regression analysis and linear
modeling where the explanatory variables
are correlated so let's look at this
problem now x i'm looking at y equals x
beta plus epsilon epsilon is is an error
but the excerpt epsilon i are
independent but the x needn't be in our
terminal so our estimator of the
coefficients are not necessarily
independent that we take our beta hat s
is the least square estimator for the
selected model s so i take only some of
these for the purpose of model selection
as related to the model can be with all
of the parameters it can be with all of
the interactions higher-order
interaction and so on so on a
complicated model and k will be the size
of that and what i have is a y hat is
their predicted given the estimator
better s and the goodness of it is y
minus y hat which is the residual sum of
square for the selected model s so this
is now depends on s and we traditionally
use this formulation with some lambda
times the number of parameters in the
model that will cover the cases known
cases of AIC and CP and the big their
old constant lambda and donna hahn
johnston's contribution is making this
lambda depend on n that is the larger
the model the larger the coefficient
that enters here purple
has to be though let's express it as a
penalized residuals with the sum of
squares as here okay I'm taking the
little salmon square adding the penalty
that was served us so well in the
independent in the orthogonal case and
notice that if I'm multiplying and
dividing by K I have the same type of
behavior but now the penalty per
parameter depends both on the potential
number of variables and on the size of
the model chosen and in fact what it has
now is that the penalty increases with
the number of variable search over but
it decreases in the model size that is
if your data tells you that you learn
more and more variables it become easier
to include the additional variable
unlike with the constant variable okay
so that's that that's the implication
from this thing okay so do these ideas I
would like just to end now they the
multiple stage procedure penalty so
instead of looking at this squared I
over N I will do it with this one with
the one I talked before which I know
that indeed the independent casework and
now let me use it in a forward selection
manner that is i will use forward
selection and do it in in a way that
will use this penalty and i want to show
you what happens from from debt in in
Justin examples okay so i give to
example the first one is diabetics data
analyzed by Efron and others when they
wanted to show the success of the loss
algorithm so you have 442 diabetics
patients you have 10 baseline
measurements for each and then you take
all interaction except sex sex squared
is simply sex then
nothing helped you and so you have
altogether 45 potential explanatory
variables in this case and you the
dependent variable is a quantitative
measure of disease progress over one
year and all you're interested is in
predictive modeling from the baseline
what would be the situation in a year
time and I'm comparing three methods one
is the multiple stage FDR which critical
point 05 the other one is a method
suggested by Wu Busan Stefanski which is
very close in nature to the false
discovery rate what they do is the
introduced random explanatory variables
into their pool of explanatory variables
they run the regression until they find
that the number of the number of
variables that they know is noise the
proportion inter sent is less than point
05 so they do as big as possible by
introducing death so they imitate FD our
idea here and in fact these two gave
exactly the same model which had 17
variables the original analysis we
choose the list angle regression
selection the last had 16 variables in
it this one resulted with point 5 r
square this one was point 5 3 r square
so it seems that they didn't adding
almost doubling the lambo variables in
the regression helped very little and in
fact this has enough of it in order to
give good results mmm okay let me go to
the second example the second example is
a logistic regression analyzing so I'm
carrying it over to logistic regression
cancer microwave data sets of normal and
Carson or lunch dishes our microarray
analysis number of prop set is about
7,000 number of cancer samples
the number of normal samples it has been
analyzed a couple of times beer hall is
the original one it was analyzed and
published by a group of researchers now
universities all save the names the goal
was to produce a stable ranked gene list
the top of which would be good set of
classifiers okay so what they did is the
following they produced 1,000 different
gene sets according to the SVM models of
sizes five up to 100 on bootstrap
samples that's the death edition
yesterday I didn't know look at me so
what they did is they boost up the the
samples keeping the 10 and 86 and we
went again svm modern selection first of
all the meetings to five then to ten ten
to twenty ten to forty all the way up to
actually they did from five on 1015 and
so on all the way up to 100 and
registered what variables entered their
SVM the SVM models and then they looked
at the highest the highest rank those
that appeared in most frequently in
those sets and the gene was the high
score was a gene reserves rage it was
called and this is the way it
distinguished between the two tissues so
these are normal samples and this is
counter samples and these are the box
plots of the gene expression level for
the two of these not great I would say
the list okay now what we did is we use
the multistage FDR penalty we also
produce 120 replication by bootstrapping
and for each replication we got the
sequence of nested model by forward
selection that is we added the one
variable then the next one then the next
one and so on and so forth we fit
logistic regression for each of the
substance on these sequence and we chose
the minimizer of the deviance which is
in the stead of the sum of squares it is
minus 2 the likelihood plus the multiple
state-of-the-art
okay and we did it 150 times and the
result was that in all replication only
one gene was needed no more than one
gene and here is the box plot of the
separation by the top jeans in this case
for the six top ones by themselves they
perfectly this one perfectly distinguish
between the normal and the cancer and so
is this one and just one except two one
all the others except for one patient
distinguish entirely now what happens
there how can this extensive thing nice
and and this simple forward selection
but controlling for the fact that you
select a few for many why does it give
you such a thing such a good thing well
the point is that the possibility of
selection offered is so big that noise
overwhelms the nose created by the
selection completely overwhelmed the the
two underlying small features so in this
is an example where the fact that you
don't have power is better than you will
impair but but it will save you today
the question of model selection our
puzzle selection is just model selection
you select a subset of the variable so
far we've talked about model selection
in prediction but the last example
actually shows that even if you do
prediction you're interested in what you
found I mean the interest here is not
willing to get a good prediction but to
understand what is by what was it
predicted that that explanatory think is
of if of answers and so the question is
what interpretation can we give to the
parameters in the model selected with
FDR penalty hopefully we would like to
have some property like we are
protecting the fourth dimension rate
that is the dimension we included the
model I do not exactly promises we don't
have a zero interpretation
for for the parameter but it we don't
have to larger proportion of death it is
not clear our current theory doesn't
give us doesn't give us a help of that
because remember as we move on the
parameters change to estimate the change
the p-value something that was a big p
value before once a new variable enters
the p value may deteriorate and they get
better or my hunch is that it is indeed
control maybe with some small adjustment
but it's I don't know the second
question is is this forward selection
path that I was using is it essential
what about the law school the last part
or subsidy mean other things that one
can use and for model selection but you
still want to in fear about what
existing new model and and and makes a
statement and about the size of it and
make confidence interval and so on now
this is really at the core of current
work I think in the area actually three
current papers out of Stanford teams
deal with testing along the LA Zoo path
while controlling the sides of the model
using FDR idea the wool from the last
half-year essentially the first one of
these is the idea of data splitting well
you develop the model on half of your
data and you estimate the significance
and confidence interval on the other
half of the data the other one r is
synthetic p values for the LA zoo path
when you introduce new variable into the
low souza a third one is a sequential
testing idea that might be looked at
there and the full one is this paper bye
canderson quarter or introduces sorted
l1 version of FDR penalty which is neat
because what it does is that we looked
at this penalty okay least square plus
this and in the spirit of in the spirit
of the laws you're taking not merely the
absolute values
of each of the coefficient but your x a
penalty depending on the order it is so
the largest one you give a large penalty
the smaller you get the spoil of the
penalty and you minimize that and so you
can use ideas from least squares and no
you can avoid using these squares and
the computational complexities and
instead use other things are these are
two new I am just pointing it the fact
that there is a lot that is going on in
this direction it is something that that
we are working on part of it with Philip
more on the confidence interval part of
it after model selection but it doesn't
have yet a good answer so somebody asked
me there in the beginning we don't have
that a good answer but I think we have
in terms of the selection part we do
have
no okay
now that's what I said before I just
want to mention that part of the
interest is because of the recent result
of birth town and puja that solved the
problem entirely but solved it in the
family wise they already control over
all possible selected models I mean they
solved a huge problem by solving the
huge problems they protect against any
model selection at the expense of
extremely long confidence interval that
go like the square root of m m is the
number of potential coefficient so in
fact it's just making the statement this
is an open and open for them how to
utilize the selection process in order
to get reasonable inferences okay um I
have about 15 minutes i as i said okay i
will start with that and then stopping
the middle and move to another yeah I
understood correctly the the underlying
modeling here is that you you've got
this quickly decaying
list of sort of good trooper like in the
case of Independence you had you were
assuming that the means were quickly
decaying and you were looking for the
those poor signal yes person uh you're
looking for that heavy part I guess a
different approach would be to not
assume anything about the sequence and
just hope to get something like the best
the best like a small set of good
variables or you know just to be
competitive with the best small set as
opposed to okay recovering everything
and I guess I was just wondering if if
these analyses sort of our general
enough to encompass that kind of setting
also okay they're the kind of
theoretical analysis that was done was
done for included many types of sports
bodies for spas so they can be l two
balls I've been the Sobel of balls I
mean all kind of this theoretical stuff
but in particular they can they if they
go if they're old on zero they go down
fast enough to do and so on so forth in
terms of theoretical analysis I don't
find it very useful to study specific
things in specific things i would i
would do it in terms of finite finite
the problem sighs and if i had problems
eyes i couldn't be here we did some
extensive simulation studies the sum of
all kind of dependencies and so on and
got sort of the least favorable
situation protection against the list
rebel situation was very good by this
segment was actually they're the best
and had one more thing which is
asymptotically similar to death and in
soy died it is hard for me to see how
you can wear very limited results under
the normal token on situation so i don't
see the point of getting final results
in the orthogonal case why really we
always face almost always face the
normal terminal case
if an effort is to be done it should be
done in maybe even smaller problems but
once that are realistically in the
situation so far it's mostly done with
simulation and not with but it's a
challenge it's certainly a challenge
we'll need to finish your ballot will
have another presentation after yours
seven more minutes can you seven more
minutes okay so i will just finish with
two things first of all i was talking
about the family a friend a family and
in fact this last part i wanted to talk
about families of families in the very
diverse way and what i wanted to
emphasize that what there seems to be
ambiguity about the notion of a family
for me it is defined by the possibility
of selection so family should be a
family is the richest set of influences
in an analysis all achieving the same
goal from which once selected influence
could be replaced by another selected
influence for presentation for
highlighting or for action so it is
different researchers can have different
goals and does define differently the
families but still decisions can be
defendable and with no arbitrariness
okay and an example is the medical
research where you have usually a
comparable or clinical trial will you
have central group and the treatment
group and you first do a baseline
comparison does a lot of people use
about baseline comparison then you have
effective length of their selves and you
might have six or seven measures of the
effectiveness of the results one of them
will be called primary endpoints the
other one will not but those described
the efficacy of the drug and then you
will have another table describing the
safety now one cannot take something
from safety and bring it to the baseline
or to their fickes e each one has a goal
by itself and so the goal is defining
the goal and the ability of one
replacing the other not to make a
statement is what
finds her family and I will immediately
go to do to the once i presented here
that really the researcher didn't do the
analysis this way but the way they
presented the results they define their
own families because what they did and
this is a family of families what they
did is they first selected the five top
jeans they weren't significant by the
circuit front of jeans so that means
that they looked at that Jesus as a big
family and they selected only five then
for each slip they selected the family
of interesting findings from where from
different regions on the vein so they
looked at all of this is one family and
made their selection and didn't matter
it was here or there so the researchers
reveal in fact what is for them a family
or not you can argue with that or you
can agree with them but it's not
something of a jury that's the point I'm
trying to make and with this not I will
go to the last point that I was I wanted
to make and this is our selective
inference challenges in open access data
which might be of particular interest to
that well we are now having more and
more cases of open data and that's
really what you are dealing with in
either way you'll be no you're dealing
with the problem of confidentiality and
open data we have the same problem with
selective influence when open data for
instance the European community have
decided that as of January first of 2014
all clinical trials results should be
deposited in an open access database on
individual patient level individual
patients level and should be available
for other people to study to reanalyze
are to look for a different result and
so on and so forth so the question is
immediate that of selective inference
suppose that you will have this 100
different people going to the same
database and asking again again at the
end something will come out so it's just
to know that they're actually FD our
ideas can be adapted to that one family
wiser or completely cannot because if
the family wiser already firmly you have
to know from the beginning the size of
the family and it's all seems that I to
so far have discussed on the issues
where the size of the family is given
beforehand but that doesn't have to be
the case in fact over there over the
break right I talked with a new mode
Megiddo and I presented this tree of
hypothesis and in fact say that we can
have control over it three of hypothesis
that will give us control whatever the
tree is whatever the trees which means
we don't have to know it beforehand but
the only point is that we do not
continue with something or two points we
do not continue with something unless it
was significant and at each level of the
tree we do FDR testing at level Q and
think is it doesn't more than doubles
the FDR double x 1.4 for something like
that which is the upper bar another idea
is that by Foster and Stein they talk
about alpha investment to control the
level alpha hill they are talking about
hypothesis coming at a row okay and you
control actually if it was if I were f1
I was put here little big FDR and here a
little FDR because they are talking
about a of V divided by e FR and just
add a little bit of Mewtwo the numerator
take it away from 0 it's not that
essential and the hypothesis arrived
sequentially in the study and you test a
chai with alpha i defined beforehand but
that can be modified that is if you
rejected I then alpha I plus 1 the next
one will be larger why because if you're
projected yuvan Chris to you then
later while if you've not rejected you
might have been adding to the present
value V so it thinks is being modified
and it's a very nice idea they weren't
thinking at that time about open data
access open access data but it is really
appropriate to think about it in the way
and in fact our own Ian will set just
recently suggested an optimal rule for
that and if i combine it with quality
preserving database idea that if you
take if you go and analyze the database
you have to contribute some new cases
and they showed that if you do that you
don't have to continue with much cases
and actually while everyone seems to be
using more and more smaller smaller
alpha to decide that the rejection has
occurred in fact the power remains
stable so the fact that cases are aided
you have you keep the stable power at
the same time so the point I'm making is
I think this ideas that are right for
further utilization and can be used to
address issues in open access data okay
so let me finish by reflecting on the
outline I talked about simultaneous and
selective inference making the
distinction talking about the family I
how they talked about well should be
used simultaneously or selectively
notice I talked about the many other
error rates that were are being explored
sort of in between like the probability
that false discovery proportion will not
be less than point 05 would be bigger
than point 95 and things somewhat more
complicated on that level I didn't talk
about that testing was FDR control I
talked about the bh deducted bh ideal
talk at all about resampling which is
heavily used in genetics where you have
the original observation and I mentioned
just empirical base in the full coverage
rate i did talk both generally and
tailored to their selection I didn't
talk about complex selection or about
the issue of dependency
which creates a problem and in the
estimation and model selection I talked
about FDR pressure holding its
equivalents in terms of penalized M&C it
showed some example I didn't talk about
conditional estimators and just
mentioned the fact that we have a
problem with most model selection
influence and I didn't talk at all about
more complex family so let us up up that
I hope that you will carry over from
this talk is that you have to worry
about the fact of selection if you get
out from here with this resisting in
mind I've done a good job it might be
love to show properties on the average
of the selected which is what the FDR a
thought is doing and there are simple
and useful methods for testing
confidence interval and the idea seemed
to be imported another situation for
analysis of big data large inference
problems like model selection and open
data access and there are many
challenges that still exist in the area
and I'm sure that more chances will come
as the scientific questions become too
or the practical questions come to mind
thank you yeah so how about great so you
use selective examples to show us in
size of the FDR you forgot my lab rest
my [ __ ] what you actually selected few
good examples to demonstrate good
question especially since I have an
answer so there is a recent paper in
biostatistics where Nick and his wife
there are Shakira I think actually try
to answer the question by looking by
mining all the upsets of five leading
medical journals in the Journal of
Medicine
british journal of medicine and so the
54 leading journals and the and the
fifth one was an epidemiology Jonah
mining all of the p value statements in
them and trying to estimate from that
that false discovery false science-wise
discovery rate so science-wise false
discovered so actually looking at the
phenomena and they publish this result
they came out with a very low figure
point 15 a we not only discussed this
paper but use the software which was
reproducible research and we could
easily do that and together with your
thumb and half Legare we actually try to
look at it again actually sampling
papers looking they mind abstract
looking at what is the relationship
between what appears in the paper what
in the abstract and so on and so forth
what I can say is that I I was very
merciful in my examples okay we estimate
it to be much closer to somewhere
between 25 and 40 percent and this is
because of the phenomenal selection into
dr. I mean you see the paper everything
is scattered is you know significant
period was not significant value but
then in the absurd so is the significant
that when that appears and so on so it's
I don't think we'd head we fall I don't
think we fell into this trip together
you mentioned at the very end this is of
interesting problem when policies are
being present adaptively like the I
what if they can become cleaning wounds
right this is a person eat imaginary
some fresh for handling this does it
need to know what the sort of tree is
for what for the tree structure think
you can develop the tree while you're
doing testing that's great because you
need independence so that that's a good
thing about this so in science what I
envisioned hopefully will happened is
that I mean a scientist works continues
to work on something that seems to be
promising so so in this case a scientist
here has decided to create a study
because this was significant project
that appears in the paper and so on only
continues today now he's continuing it
by himself okay and if he makes a
finding someone else will continue and
so on but they the practice of
meta-analysis where you collect all
studies made by independent researchers
look at them in a combined way this is
essentially doing this step or doing
distant so it is true that the tree is
in some sense growing faster in this
direction they're back but that's the
point I'm trying to I'm when I talk
about apply to emphasize the importance
of meta-analysis to keep on us that the
unity factors an example if i think
tamil feeling i mean the the drug
against it against the virus that was
both to the market in huge quantities
for the birds flew okay so there was
there was an analysis of effect and
there was about the i think 12 different
studies but essentially only one of them
was a very strong results and when you
that all 12 together and look from this
point of view not from combining
everything together because
meta-analysis sometimes simply combines
the thing but you looked at the question
is the rid of evidence you would say no
there's not enough evidence so it's true
that it was done after the case but it
can protect their scientific progress in
a very nice one